do you constantly find things you want
to read or watch on the Internet
only did it get distracted by other
things you want to read or watch do you
then remember you have to get back to
doing real work and forget about all
those other things you wanted to read or
watch you may be suffering from idd
internet distraction disorder but
there's a way to ease the symptoms
without having to talk to your doctor ab
Slyke pocket instapaper and readability
I'll let you save the good stuff so you
can concentrate on it later but they're
not all created equal
yes some have side effects there are two
simple steps to using these apps the
first is save and most of these apps let
you save in the same way here's how it
works you sign up for an account and on
your computer's browser you install a
small bookmarklet when you see a video
article or really any webpage you want
to save click the button and it's log to
your account you can access it in the
app later with the iPhone iPad or
Android phone or tablet apps you can
save things by tapping on the share
button Facebook has its own similar
feature you can tap here and select save
for later you can then access them from
the Facebook save file but not all these
apps are as good when it comes to step 2
reading or watching of all the apps I
tested I like pocket and Instapaper the
best both apps format articles for
reading and let you adjust text size
font and brightness I really liked how
pocket displays those tools and how you
can swipe to turn the page
pockets Android app lets you take
reading material on the road with its
read aloud feature Instapaper already
has read aloud features on both its
Android and iOS apps and has other
features pocket dozen including notes
tools and a speed reading feature sadly
there's no feature to help you speed up
watching videos sorry about that
but instapaper isn't perfect it had
problems pulling in photos in many
articles all I got was text and the
design just feels a bit dated Instapaper
does let you follow friends and see what
they've saved but I wish all these apps
went further with both video and article
discovery other apps like Flipboard and
pulse do that well but they're real ATAR
features are buried and not as good
so I continued my search for the perfect
all-in-one reading app but for now when
Internet distraction disorder hits
pocket is my drug of choice pocket does
not cause dizziness nausea or heart
attacks Amer instances it may cause
illiteracy do you not take pocket and
operating large machinery consult your
doctor at pocket lasts for more than
four hours